today
starts a landmark trial
that will be a referendum on how far
america has come in its quest
for equality and justice for all
it will be prima facie
evidence this trial
of derek shoving regarding the killing
of george floyd
on may 25th 2020 right here in
minneapolis
it will be prima facie evidence
whether america is going to live up
to the declaration of independence now i
know
everybody can quote the declaration of
independence but this trial is going to
provide
evidence of whether we really believe
it when we say we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men
are created equally that they're endowed
by their creator
with certain inalienable rights that
amongst them
are life and liberty in the pursuit of
happiness
well america that means black people too
america that means george floyd too
and for all of those people reverend now
who continue to say
that this is such a difficult trial
that this is such a hard trial
well we rebuked that this song
because we know if george floyd
was a white american citizen
and he suffered this painful
torturous death with a police officer
kneeling his neck
nobody nobody nobody will be saying
this is a hard case right and when
people
ask you that activists and
the family thanks to activists when
people ask you
well isn't this a tough case because
they're going to try to say
george floyd had a trace amount of drugs
in his system you let them know that ben
crump said
that george floyd was living
breathing walking and talking
just fine until the police put him
face down and put him in handcuffs
and put a knee on his neck for eight
minutes
and 46 seconds so
this murder case is not hard
when you watch that torture video of
george floyd
you all understand this murder case
is not hard when you watch
that torture video of george floyd
and we have to call it what is it it was
torture even under the geneva convention
definition
this was torture and
derek chauvin should be held criminally
liable
for the death of george floyd
you know we
the civil lawyers
made sure that george lloyd family got
their civil justice
under the seventh amendment tony with
the historic
27 million dollar settlement
that not only included compensation for
the family
but also policy reform
and that is important but that's only
part of the justice
george floyd just like any other
citizen his family is
deserving of whole justice
for justice that means that the state
and the agents of the government shall
hold
individuals who commit crimes
accountable under the 10th amendment
and black people in america should not
only have to get partial justice
we have every right
to get whole justice civil justice
and criminal justice nobody questioned
it
when the diamond family got a 20 million
dollar settlement
this song that that white family should
not also
get criminal justice so why is it
that we will question in 2021
whether black people in america can get
whole justice as well under the seventh
amendment
and the tenth amendment we're not asking
for anything extraordinary
we're asking for equal justice under the
law
and news flash news splash
breaking news
we expect in just a few minutes you're
going to hear
opening arguments and they're going to
take the playbook out reverend allen
they're going to try
to assassinate the character of george
floyd
for loners they're going to call your
brother everything
for the child of god and they're going
to talk about
as much as they can about
his record but his record
isn't an issue all right because this is
the trial
of derek sheldon come on breaking news
this is the trial of derek sheldon let's
talk about
his record all right his 19 complaints
of excessive voice
by citizens here in minneapolis that's
what we should be talking about
george floyd didn't kill anybody derek
sheldon
was the person that killed george floyd
so
where is it we will allow them to
assassinate the character
of george floyd after they assassinated
his person y'all
they taught me in law school that if you
have the facts on your side then by all
means
argue the facts but then they said
if the facts ain't really with you then
try to assassinate your opponent's
character
as a way to hopefully distract everybody
from focusing in on the facts well
everybody please do not be distracted
the facts are simple what killed george
floyd
was an overdose of excessive force come
on bro
the transcript from the autopsies are
clear
the manner and cause of death
was a fixation by homicide
bologna said in the hood they choked
it was a neat show and so
let's remember the facts here
this murder case is not hard
just look at the torture video of george
floyd
when anybody asks you remind them
this murder case is not hard
just look at the torture video
of george floyd the most viewed
murder of a police on a citizen
in the history of the world it has been
viewed just and over 50 million times on
youtube
and probably as many more times on cable
television
everybody has saw this video what we
want to know
is will we seek justice the whole world
is watching
the whole world is watching so you're
going to hear from
attorney tony ramon nucci attorney
justin miller and attorney
jeff stars and then you're gonna hear
from the family of george floyd
and then after that you're gonna hear
from our civil rights leader
america's civil rights leader al
sharpton we're trying to time it where
we can get it right at eight
minutes and 46 8 46
and we're going to try to keep time and
then
reverend now after he gives us
our call to action we're going to take a
knee
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds
and hopefully everybody within the sound
of his voice
will join us in taking that need to
understand
what george floyd went through
the last minutes and seconds of his life